Imaginez qu'une planète s'étaient jusqu'ici caché dans notre système solaire
elle était sur la même orbite que la terre mais juste derrière le soleil ce qui fait que personne n'avait pu l'observer
on y voit des astronautes et là surprise
c'est un clone de la planète terre mais totalement cubique à quoi ça ressemblerait d'y vivre à sa surface
quels sont les problèmes de physique qu'on y rencontrerait et surtout que faudrait-il pour qu'une telle planète prennent cette forme dans la réalité
pour cette expérience on va étudier des logiciels 3d et le minecraft préparez vous pour un grand voyage
avec la limmat art qu'est ce que ça ferait d'être sur les bords d'une planète cubique
l'atterrissage sur la plaine public s'est bien passé lui c'est notre astronautes qui débarque et salles là bas ou moins c'est le bord du monde
c'est étonnant mais contrairement la terre
l'horizon s'étend du pernois normal puisque la face sur laquelle on est est totalement plate pas de courbure pour gâcher le spectacle
comme vous êtes curieux de savoir ce que ça fait quand on est sur les bords
mitton nous en août déjà sur le chemin un truc bizarre ce produit plus on s'éloigne plus on a l'impression de monter
c'est pourtant impossible les façons totalement plate c'est à cause d'une chose toute simple
la gravité cette force qui semble nous tirer vers le centre de la planète
sur la terre sérique le centre est sous nos pieds qu importe où vous soyez en france
en australie le centre est à la même distance
mais sur une planète cubi plus on se rapproche d'un bord plus on s'éloigne du centre de la planète et plus cette direction est incliné
et ça vous pouvez le vérifier avec une simple feuille de papier en
réalité les côtes du cube sont pour toi comme des sortes de chic quand est-ce que montagne de 3000 kilomètres de pau
la perception de la verticale est totalement chamboulé le monde a beau être carré
gravitationnellement tu le ressens direct comme ça il n'y a qu'au centre où tu aurais le sentiment de gravité normal tout lors
sc de la pente
si tu lâches un ballon alors qu'il est en train de monter le long d'à côté il ne va pas tomber tout droit au sol
il va rouler vers le centre du carré et tu commences à voir le problème
les bords de la planète ne sont ni verdoyant ni aquatique
clos va être attirés vers le centre de cette immense cuve est
gravitationnelle ce qui fait qu'il y aura littéralement une pub l'océan au centre de chaque phase de la planète public bon ça s'annonce mal mais
continuons l'ascension heureusement plus on s'éloigne du centre - subit la gravité et donc pèsent moins lourd ça représente
60% de notre poids habituel
c'est déjà ça mais petit à petit il fait de plus en plus froid et ta respiration devient difficile on arrive en fait aux
limites de la bulle atmosphérique dont on a retiré les rebelles est là qu il faut maintenant te retirer l'air et le ciel
peut aussi sont attirés vers le centre pour former une bulle est justement là on arrive aux limites de cette bulle atmosphérique
au delà c'est le vide spatial et oui sur une place publique on peut aller dans l'espace à pied mais vous ce qui vous intéresse
c'est de savoir ce qu'il y à holly mythe du cube qu'est ce que ça fait de pouvoir
s'asseoir sur les rebords du monde eh bien
désolé mais tu tomberas pas tu pourras te tenir debout au sommet du monde en équilibre comme si tu étais au sommet d'une montagne
tu te sentirais très léger et tu pourrez contempler une vue magnifique sur
quatre face de la planète sauf que il ya quelque chose qui cloche
si face si paysages très différents au sommet de la montagne gravitationnelle tu découvres qu'une d'effacer complètement
glacée est morte et oui sur une terre ronde
l'inclinaison fait qu'on ne reçoit pas la même quantité de soleil suivant notre
position est le moment de l'année mais sur une terre cubique tous les rayons arrive avec le même englobe pas de saison pas de fuseaux
horaires toujours 12 heures de jour et 12 heures de nuit soit l'axé vertical et passe par deux faces
là deux faces polaire qui ne reçoivent quasiment jamais de lumière
glacée est morte ou sinon quatre phases qui en reçoivent un
maximum c'est l'été toute l'année assez aride comme qui m'a quand même
mais si on prend comme notre terre un axe incliné les deux faces polaire seront dans la nuit la moitié de l'année et
assisteront à un coucher de soleil 2
mois c'est déjà en quelque sorte ce qu'il se passe au pôle et sur les autres face à peu près le même climat qu'on a
actuellement en europe mais le paramètre à prendre le plus en compte c'est que chaque fois c'est totalement séparées par du vide spatial
ce qui fait que l'atmosphère reste au centre qui rend impossible les grands mouvements d'air et d'eau qui régule la température sur notre terre
pas de perturbation ni de vents violents
toujours la même météo au même rythme pour des
millions d'années mais si tu veux de l' aventure rappelle toi que toutes les bulles d'atmosphère sont
totalement séparés il ya littéralement si monde en un
autrement dit la vie qui s'est développée sur une autre face à peut-être suivi une évolution
complètement différente pas besoin de chercher très loin des aliens pourrait se trouver sur la même planète
est ce que la vie est possible sur une planète cubique
rappelle toi quand on a dit que l'atmosphère former une bulle sur chaque face et ça c'est pas sans conséquence au centre
l'atmosphère y tellement compris mais qu'on atteint des pressions des températures énorme
c'est une cocotte-minute plus truc hors de question d'y vivre al'inverse au delà de la bulle cannoise aux mains d'air et celle vide spatial
ce qui nous laisse une zone habitable
réduite un anneau d'une quarantaine de kilomètres de large pas grand du tout qu'ils croient marathon
était arrivé à l'autre bout un marathon un peu particulier puisque à cause de la montagne
gravitationnelle tu serais tout temps penché comme si tu étais en permanence en forte pente ce monde serait plutôt adapté
des chamois par exemple parce que j'ai oublié de vous dire mais ouais
vous avez beau être à plat vous pouvez tomber et glisser vers le centre c'est la mort assurée tellement les conditions sont extrêmes
ça ne veut pas non plus dire que la vie au centre serait impossible
par exemple au fond des océans on pourrait retrouver ce genre de poisson
abyssal ou des limaces de mer des mariannes le vertébrés qui vit le plus en profondeur au monde
les hautes températures n'est prêt pas quant à elle les bactéries hyperthermophiles qui elle se régale de la présence des magmas à
proximité des volcans sous marins al'inverse vers l'extérieur lorsque l'air se raréfie on pourrait retrouver des edelweiss
surnommés les toiles des glaciers car elle arrive à pousser à des altitudes
impressionnante où l'air se fait très rare
comme on l'a dit nous humains nous ne pouvons vivre que sur ce petit anneau il y en a un autre
très propice à la vie et c'est celui légèrement vers l'intérieur l'air il serait tellement dense et épais qu'on pourrait presque
nager dedans il est très probable que les oiseaux soient
favorisés par ces conditions du coup suivant la distance au centre la biodiversité et l'environnement seront très différents on passerait d'une sorte de
vénus au centre a eu un terreau fertile une mars et enfin paysage lunaire tout ça sur la même planète
à quelques kilomètres de marche avec les pressions et températures
immonde au centre on n'est pas sûr que le cycle de l'eau pourra s'accomplir or sans pluie pas d'eau
non pas de vie mais le spectacle le plus fou ce
passera le soir comme on l'a dit le centre est une immense bulle d'eau de 30000 mètres de haut
tu auras droit chaque soir à un coucher de soleil à travers une montagne océans une scène féerique
unique en son genre
mais interpublic est ce vraiment possible
vous en doutez une planète cubique ce n'est pas normal
la planète chercheur a fatalement à reprendre sa position d'équilibré une sphère dis toi que les arêtes sont équivalentes à des montagnes de 3000
kilomètres de haut à côté les huit kilomètres de l'everest font pâle figure
même la roche ne peut pas soutenir tout ce poids et avec le temps la terre va petit à petit se
ratatiner s'effondrer se tasser bref
s'arrondir au bout de quelques milliers d'années elle sera redevenu une banale ce faire
dommage en même temps c'est vrai qu'une planète cubique on se demande bien comment elle se serait formé
d'ailleurs quand un astronome suisse a fait les gros titres en déclarant avoir trouvé une plaine public en orbite autour de neptune
même le new york times s'est moqué de lui parce que oui c'était faux alors qu'avez vous pensé du voyage en explorant cette étrange planète
je ne pensais pas qu'il y aurait autant de choses à découvrir
imaginez seulement la beauté d'un tel paysage et que j'aimerais tellement pouvoir le voir si non en vrai au moins dans un jeu vidéo
je laisse la porte ouverte aux créateurs aux rêveurs au dessinateur en espérant un jour pouvoir voir ce monde en mouvement
planète québec
pensez à vous abonner à la chaîne sayan strache si vous voulez une suite avec d'autres formes de planètes
s'étaient Neoxys, Mathart, Sky et Antoine aidé de tous les moteurs merci à vous tous Tchao !